>>> AND WE'RE BACK WITH OUR
WORLD LEAD.
U.S. OFFICIALS SAY THAT UP TO
100 UKRAINIAN TROOPS ARE SET TO
BEGIN TRAINING AT FORT SILL IN
OKLAHOMA NEXT WEEK ON HOW TO USE
THE PART AIR DEFENSE MISSILE
SYSTEM.
THE UKRAINIANS NEED IT TO SHOOT
DOWN INCOMING RUSSIAN MISSILES
AND DRONES.
ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE,
INTENSE FIGHTING HAS BEEN
REPORTED.
BEN WEDEMAN IS BACK FROM THE
FRONT LINES NORTH OF THERE NEAR
CRIMEA.
>> Reporter: THIS COMMANDER IS
FINALIZING THE COORDINATES FOR A
STRIKE ON THE TOWN OF KREMMNA.
BEFORE THE WAR, MAX WAS AN
ENGLISH TEACHER.
HIS BRIGADE HAS SEEN ACTION IN
THE BATTLES OF KYIV, KHARKIV AND
NOW DONBAS.
THEIR TARGET TODAY, A BUILDING
IN KREMMNA WHERE HE SAYS ATTACK
DRONES ARE LAUNCHED AGAINST
UKRAINIAN FORCES.
THIS ARTILLERY SYSTEM IS KNOWN
AS A PEON, 233 MILLIMETERS.
THE ROUNDS WEIGH 100 KILOS, 220
POUNDS.
THIS IS A SYSTEM USED BOTH BY
THE RUSSIANS AND THE UKRAINIANS.
THE COLD HERE CHILLS TO THE BONE
MAKING THIS WORK ALL THE MORE
DIFFICULT.
TO PROTECT AGAINST RUSSIAN
DRONES, THEY'VE DEPLOYED A
SPECIAL WEAPON THAT DEPLETES
DRONE BATTERIES.
FIRST, THE ROUND GOES INTO THE
BARREL, AND THE TRIGGER CORD IS
PULLED.
SENDING THE MASSIVE ROUND
HURDLING TOWARDS ITS TARGET 18
KILOMETERS AROUND 11 MILES AWAY.
IT FIRES AGAIN AND AGAIN.
A SPOTTER RADIOS THAT THE TARGET
HAS BEEN HIT.
HE TELLS HIS MEN TO USE SHRAPNEL
ROUNDS TO FINISH THE JOB.
>> WE DAMAGED IT, WE DESTROYED
THE BUILDING WHERE THEY HIDE AND
I SUPPOSE THEY WILL NOT MAKE
PROBLEMS FOR US IN FUTURE.
>> Reporter: A SMALL VICTORY IN
A BIG WAR.
BEN WEDEMAN, CNN NEAR KREMMNA,
EASTERN UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: AND IT DOES SEEM
THAT THE FIGHTING ACROSS THE
EASTERN UKRAINIAN FRONT IS
RAGING.
WE WERE PARTICULARLY IN THAT
TOWN.
CNN WAS ABLE TO SPEAK TO A
SOLDIER THERE WHO SA